let's talk reuniting this cast i am a
long time true fan of this series since
i was a boy i watched this movie about
an hour and a half ago and i was i was
blown out of the water we're gonna get
to the ending we won't talk about it but
you you said something i want to know
how was it reuniting with the group was
it was it instant nostalgia for you well
it's nostalgia but it's nostalgia based
on
trauma
[Music]
[Music]
you know this the first movie uh 43
years ago halloween 1978 and then the
2018 movie which
sort of reintroduced everybody to
michael and laurie um
it's exciting to see people in the new
movie we have kyle richards we have
charles ciphers we have nancy stevens
these are actors that are in the
original movie this new movie halloween
kills is about the collateral damage
that happens to a town when something
happens like the 1978 movie you know the
2018 movie focused on lori strode
happened 40 years ago
and lori strode is going to end it we
see her at the end of the movie in the
back of a truck bleeding out but she has
killed michael and saved her daughter
and granddaughter
the new movie
michael has survived
and she has been wounded she's a wounded
warrior and her daughter and her
granddaughter and the rest of the town
come together to
hunt him down because lori is wounded
all right i want to talk about those
moments in the hospital because we we
are allowed to see a softer side of lori
for a second there's a bit of flirtation
with will how was it having a softer
side of a character that's been hardened
for years now lori is lonely
lori suffered this terrible trauma
and then banged around like a pinball
through her life alcohol drugs men
alienation
isolation
and
the first day i met will patton on the
set when we were shooting the 2018 movie
i had this moment of clarity where i
realized
maybe he's the father of her daughter
maybe they were
together back in the day
one night and she's never told him
like all of a sudden a feeling of warmth
toward him in history and i started to
explore that with david and will and i
kind of whispered in his ear once
and it just sort of built a storyline
that i think we're going to explore more
and more
um that they did have history her vision
of it was that maybe she acted very
inappropriately with him and did things
she regrets he actually
says to her no it was okay
we didn't do anything and there's just a
lovely as you said a humanness to her
you say something to him and he goes
with his eyes closed he goes you're
crazy and you turn to him and you go fu
with this smirk and i was like there was
more said in those three words than any
moment it's so powerful and just so
beautiful lovely a different side of
lori but still
gloried the whole time
stop you had a knife in your stomach you
and allison
should not have to keep running
evil
dies
tonight i want to know what does the
queen of halloween
what's your halloween look like what are
you what are you doing i am so quiet on
halloween um i live in a neighborhood
where nobody comes
i used to when my children were little i
used to do it all up hang people from
the trees and you know all the
you know the accoutrements that go with
it and
spiders on the walls and all of that and
you know i
michael you said come here come here i
just need to talk to you you're saying
just come here for a second please just
come here for a second listen
back
off you seriously can you just go back
and just look scary on the house please
i'm sorry it was a good try i mean
seriously he just wants to get on camera
it's embarrassing i you know what
we'll talk later i'll
when we're in private i'll explain
he had a bad childhood and just like
looking for attention and it's he's
acting out i'm gonna need some therapy
okay
no it'll be fine
as i was saying before i was interrupted
that michael myers
i used to hang spiders and things you
know in front of my house and stuff and
i'm sure i scared some school children
so i'm so very sorry um but nobody ever
comes to my house i put the candy out
it's still all there
so um i just you know what i don't have
to do anything on halloween i don't when
my kids were little
i didn't i would have to wear a costume
so that people didn't pay attention to
me
but you know halloween is a wonderful
time
for families kids the freedom of that
and of course then this halloween the
people are going to be in the theater
not taking their kids because this is a
brutal movie this is brutal there is a
level of violence in this new movie it
feels to me that he has transcended that
he has risen from the flames
of that burning house and his level of
rage has
sort of amplified
and and his brutality has amplified and
it kind of goes with the time right now
everybody is angry
and and this is just a new level of it
and for horror fans it's a horror film
yes it is this isn't a you know rom-com
it isn't it's a horror film it's
horrific
and i think we're seeing already that
people want it they're going to the
theater they want to have an experience
and i'm telling you this will be an
experience michael myers is flesh and
blood
but a man couldn't have survived that
fire
the more he kills
the more he transcends
you said that fans may be shocked and
agitated i almost wanted to start with
this because when we started talking
earlier the ending of the film got me on
so many different levels elaborate on
shocked and agitated where does that
come from why do you think the viewers
are going to feel a little bit well the
shock is because the level of violence
has been amplified it's shocking yeah
agitated
because
there is
a direct result to that level of
violence it agitates you all of the
characters there is this group of people
hunting down it's a bit of mob violence
and that is agitating big groups of
people it's terrifying to watch a group
of people maraude through a hospital
looking for someone and that's agitating
so it's not just your classic tale
it has it feels like david gordon green
who's the writer and the director has as
a conductor is just it's that middle
section
of a
of a piece of music that has a lot of
symbols and a lot of crashing of things
it's it's that building up moment and it
starts building up and it never stops
this is a movie that takes off and runs
and so it it's different
from uh the original movie those mob
scenes are
you couldn't have described them better
i it is those were all the emotions i
felt watching those mob sins and i won't
get into them deeply but just well but
by the way it's just
mob violence is scary it's terrible
whatever side you're on whatever the
reason for it
just seeing it whatever your thoughts
it's not a political statement it's a
reality statement it's uncomfortable
it's uncomfortable it's out of control
and when you're out of control in a
movie like this
it's it's it's a real response that you
get and i mean you can i can see that it
it happened for you yeah it did and by
the way that's the goal of the i mean we
made this movie two years ago hello i
mean seriously we made it two years ago
yeah and this is why we want to see the
movie i want to have these feels from
from a slasher horror movie you want to
feel it um i want to talk real quick
about
michael myers on set now i know he just
walked through casually
together right but this is this is
a little bit of a joke
not you you're not a joke you're a good
man i mean you're not a good man you're
incredibly messed up but you whoever's
in there
are very game and have been really fun
to work with all day so thanks a lot
thank you yeah okay um yeah michael
myers on set
how how how how scary is it kept or is
there small talk mask off in between the
segments it's interesting the first
movie in 1978 the man who played michael
was john carpenter's best friend nick
castle who was a father of two little
kids his wife was around the kids were
around
and he has this big bushy head of hair
and you know there are pictures of him
standing holding the mask and he's just
hanging out he wasn't scary right he was
wonderful in the movie when you see the
movie all of the head tilts are all him
we've had different people
play michael over the years james jude
courtney who plays him
the 2018 movie and the 2021 movie
is a
is a deep
well of a man
and he kept to himself
he was not big in fraternizing
he stayed in character and i'm not
saying that that was scary when he was
out of the mask sitting by himself
but he wanted to keep the distance he
wanted
to not
be buddies
and i really respect him for it because
it
really works when you see the movie it
does so well and i i think from the
performer side of it it must have been
nice somewhat for you guys to have that
distance and it not be like hey so jamie
yeah i mean i look we're trying to
suspend
the reality of our lives and live in a
very grim reality
it's still halloween night lori has been
wounded she saved her daughter and
granddaughter but there are a lot of
angry people they're chasing somebody
they think it's michael it's a mob
it's there's a lot going on so you're
right it takes and really it's really
the skill of david gordon green and his
team
who really kept the intensity of this
movie these are all night shoots we're
out here it's eight o'clock at night or
nine o'clock at night whatever it is
we're talking about like four o'clock in
the morning that level of intensity it
wasn't it was something to be a part of
is it safe to say after 40 years and
this franchise laurie strode
earned that hospital stay where she got
to just be in the bedroom yeah but you
know what
who wants to wear a hospital girl and
you just don't want to i wore one in
halloween too they're just not
you don't look good in them they're just
shapeless excuse the pun they're just um
you know they're designed for a purpose
and it's unfortunate when you're an
actor and you have to wear one um
but
it was
a different
level for me to try to find that deep
rage
and drive and be
withheld
the the wound
stops her
and so
juggling between wanting to
step into it all but then remembering
that i can't was a challenge for me you
know i wanted to be in there i wanted to
be
i wanted that moment and lori doesn't
have those moments